[Music]  cells are the champion escape artists  able to squirm through narrow passages  less than 1/4 of their width  two new studies show that cells don't  emerge unscathed from these feats of  contortion a tight squeeze can burst the  membrane that surrounds the cell's  nucleus and damage its DNA here several  cancer cells are slithering through a  miniature obstacle course when a cell  has to struggle through a narrow  passageway its nucleus pops spilling the  green marker into its body a leaky  nucleus could be disastrous for a cell  but the studies also show that cells  quickly repair the ruptures allowing  them to return the green molecule to the  nucleus and prepare for the next tight  squeeze this finding could open the way  for a cancer treatment  if this repair process could be blocked  with a drug cancer cells might squeeze  themselves to death  [Music]